ladies and gentlemen the board it's Paul
Carpenter glad you found us and what
makes you think you'll be suited to this
position coincidence really go on well
oh bloody along my shoelace broke
[Music]
twice a dog stole my scarf hey grab that
dog
here I am well this has been a truly
forgettable experience
good job
ah you won't be working for the most
Innovative company in history
range coincidences is that what you do
here make people fall in love
oh thank you so much that's why she's in
our Fast Track program and you Paul are
not
lost something immeasurably valuable
it's one of the most powerful and
coveted items ever to exist
found you
knock knock it's a door portable door to
be specific you're not to share this
with anyone can I trust you so it goes
wherever you want to go this is
a stop in the world come on
[Music]
the portable door when you fail there
are no words to describe what Mr wells
will do to you
if you do find it this is who you come
to this company is at war with itself
we were able to influence this Satsuma
imagine what we can do to the masses I
can find a way out that's what I do
[Music]
closes the door keeps the door
do you have any idea what they do here
what